وأهم نتيجة
لهذا الحكم ستكون بالطبع أه
الالتزامات بالنسبة لإسرائيل التي
تم توضيح التزاماتها الإبلاغية
ولكن أيضا بالنسبة للدول الثالثة
الداعمة لإسرائيل والتي لديها أيضا
التزام مستقل بمنع
جانب جينو أه هم أه أيضا الآن  سوف ننظر إلى
ما تعنيه هذه الأحكام بالنسبة لهم
والتزاماتهم بموجب
القانون الدولي وعلاقتهم مع أه
إسرائيل لذلك ستكون هناك أيضاً
تداعيات أوسع وثالثة أخرى
ستتأثر بهذا
وستؤثر على إسرائيل لتلتزم بأه
هذه  إجراءات مؤقتة حسنًا الدول التي
تقدم أه إما دعمًا سياسيًا أو
دعمًا ماديًا كبيرًا أه
لإسرائيل بالطبع بحاجة إلى إعادة التفكير الآن
فيما يعنيه ذلك من الناحية القانونية
والمصطلحات القانونية وما إذا كان ذلك لا يمكن أن يعني بطريقة أو بأخرى
أنهم وأنفسهم يخاطرون أيضًا
أه بانتهاك القانون الدولي حسنًا
جنوب أفريقيا  لقد طالب بالفعل
بوقف إطلاق النار
أم ولكن بالطبع الصعوبة كانت أن
حماس ليست طرفا في النزاع
أمام المحكمة حماس طرف في
الصراع ولكن ليس في النزاع ولا
يمكن للمحكمة أن تفرض إجراءات إلا على
أطراف النزاع أم  لذلك
كان من الصعب جدًا على المحكمة
أن تفرض "أم" على إسرائيل وأن
تقول إنه يتعين عليها تعليق
العمليات العسكرية بينما لا يمكنها في
الوقت نفسه فرض إجراء مماثل على حماس،
ولهذا السبب ربما
امتنعوا عن القيام بذلك.  بأن الحكم
ملزم لإسرائيل كعضو في
محكمة اتفاقيات الإبادة الجماعية
للأمم المتحدة لذا
فهي ملزمة بهذا أه بهذه
الإجراءات المؤقتة وعليها بالتالي الالتزام بها
لذلك طلبت المحكمة من إسرائيل منع
الإبادة الجماعية من  ملتزمًا بالتأكد من
أن قواته المسلحة لا ترتكب
أعمال إبادة جماعية أيضًا لمنع التحريض على
ارتكاب إبادة جماعية لمعاقبة
ذلك أه لاتخاذ تدابير
فورية وفعالة
للتخفيف من محنة
الشعب الفلسطيني في غزة وأيضًا لجعل  مؤكد
أنه لم يتم إتلاف أي دليل وعلى إسرائيل
أن تقدم تقريراً إلى المحكمة خلال شهر واحد
أه ما فعلته وماذا
تفعل للامتثال لتلك
الإجراءات